did Queen Elizabeth II hate to watch the
crown apparently she was a regular
viewer even if she detested how one
character was portrayed and no it wasn't
her in addition to receiving numerous
awards for his cast costumes and effects
Netflix says the crown has earned its
share of criticisms particularly
regarding its relationship to real life
history the series focuses on the lives
of the royal family starting when Queen
Elizabeth II unexpectedly becomes Queen
at the young age of 25. but For Better
or Worse the crown has landed on my head
while its individual storylines that
arrived from actual events much of the
show is embellished consisting of
fictionalized accounts of conversations
and interactions that may or may not
have actually happened at one point the
United Kingdom's culture secretary
Oliver Dowden said that the crown should
add a fiction disclaimer daudin told the
male on Sunday I fear generation of
viewers who did not live through these
events May mistake fiction for fact
while both Netflix and the Crown Creator
Peter Morgan have stated they believe
audiences to be smart enough to figure
out that the show is in fact fiction
this sentiment is not shared by all
relevant parties Helena Barnum Carter
who portrays Princess Margaret in
seasons 3 and 4 told the official
podcast for the show The Crown is
dramatized I do feel very strongly
because I think we have a moral
responsibility to say hang on guys this
is not it's not a drama duck we're
making a drama so there are two
different entities while many Royals
have made it clear they aren't fans of
Netflix's the crown the late Queen
Elizabeth II expressed that she was most
upset about how Prince Philip was
portrayed as a callous and insensitive
father to Prince Charles a senior Royal
source told Express she was particularly
annoyed at a scene in which Philip has
no sympathy for a plainly upset Charles
while he is flying him home from
Scotland in season 2 episode 9 Prince
Philip flies a clearly upset Prince
Charles home from Gordon Stern after
Charles attempts and fails about
participate in a school challenge as
Philip tries to tell Charles how he did
during the challenge is of no
consequence to him Charles looks
frightened and anxious as they fly
through turbulence Philip continues with
his pep talk telling Charles it's just
air Philip then tells his son that he's
weak and orders him to the back of the
plane the senior whale source told
Express that simply did not happen
despite her distaste for the way the
crown depicts Prince Philip's
relationship with the Young Prince
Charles it's since been publicly
revealed that Queen Elizabeth II did in
fact regularly watch the crown on
Netflix her report by Entertainment
Weekly recounts how during a broadcast
of the Queen's funeral leading Royal
Authority George jobson happened to
mention that Queen Elizabeth II once
made a habit of watching the crown on
Sundays he even broughts up the fact
that Prince Philip would sometimes
discourage his wife from tuning in
knowing that it would make her upset
this latter detail suggests that the
relationship between Prince Philip and
Prince Charles might not have been the
Queen's only gripe with the show but
rather one of many given that it mines
their real lives for drama it's no
surprise that members of the royal
family may have taken issue with some of
the contents of the crown of course
while series Creator Peter Morgan has
stated he plans to make at least six
seasons whether or not Queen Elizabeth
has seconds passing affects the show's
future could remain a point of Interest
moving forward